and there was a an extremely powerful
video that emerged last night put
together by players
we talked earlier this week about the
things the NFL could do to take
advantage of this moment with the assets
and resources the NFL has the messages
that could be created the commercials
the videos the PSAs all the things they
could do it took a group of players to
put together the most powerful thing I
have seen yet in response to this moment
here it is it's been 10 days I was
[Music]
not be silenced peacefully protest it
shouldn't take this long love it so this
is what we the players would like to
hear you state we condemned racism and a
systematic oppression of black people
wrong and silenced and our players from
peacefully protesting we leave black
lives matter black lives matter black
lives
just an incredible piece of work the
moment that it pivots from what if I
were George Floyd to DeAndre Hopkins the
Cardinals receiver saying I am George
Floyd and then one after another after
another it there's just something
visceral about it I've watched that
thing between 50 100 times and and I
encourage people to watch it again again
again and again because it hammers home
the message of what people are demanding
of what the concern is
and the mistreatment that African
Americans have faced at the hands of law
enforcement not just for the past few
years but forever for the 244 years that
this country has been in existence so we
encourage you to watch that over and
over again share it with your friends if
it does not affect you you are not human
big cat yeah and it has a message that
is as concise and direct as you saw just
there like it doesn't leave it up to
chance here it's not ambiguous what
they're asking the NFL to do and you
know that that specific point because it
will get to Drew Brees in a second here
what's happened a lot in the past is
there's been a little bit of a
misdirection like well it's about this
or it's about this not by obviously the
minority community but by the majority
community and saying oh it's about the
flag and it's about something else this
was as direct as it could be and it's
it's it's right there in front of you
this is what these guys are saying to
you the NFL and what will your answer be
and Mike I don't I don't know what will
their answer be when we have the
football comeback and players are
kneeling is it going to try are people
going to try to run the same playbook as
they did excuse me in 2016
Mickey and about the flag making about
the military disrespect when that's
never been about that is that how the
NFL will react or are they going to
actually listen and let players
peacefully protest here's hoping that
deflection becomes as quaint as stick to
sports by the time we get to September
now the NFL before the video emerged had
posted a message on Instagram saying
this this is a time of self-reflection
for all the NFL is no
exception we stand with the black
community because black lives matter
through inspired change the NFL players
and our partners have supported programs
and initiatives throughout the country
to address systemic racism we will
continue using our platform to challenge
the injustice around us to date we have
donated 44 million to support hundreds
of worthy organizations this year we are
committing an additional 20 million to
these causes and we will accelerate
efforts to highlight their critical work
we know that we can and need to do more
again that emerged before the video and
the New England Patriots the only team
that has retweeted that video with the
message black lives matter but that's
just part of what the players want they
also want a commitment that they will
not be prevented from peacefully
protesting that is the rewind to 2017
that is the aftermath of Colin
Kaepernick's unemployment and the
reaction to the comments that were made
by the president in Alabama on a Friday
night in September the NFL was turned on
its head when it comes to protests
during the national anthem and the
debate that raged beyond that big cat
there hasn't been anything from the
league on that the clock is ticking on
that and my question to the league here
today based upon the video that was
published last night by the players will
you say we support not we will passively
tolerate or the rules technically allow
it or you can do it in the tunnel or no
we actively support your right to
peacefully protest even if it happens
during the national anthem will they say
that that's what the clock is ticking on
and that's a great point by you Mike
because there is definitely the work
around that the NFL has used in the past
and can use here where they say you know
we we support the right all of our
players have to you know speak on the
issues that affect them by not saying
specifically you can kneel if you want
to during the protean the national
anthem so and this is a situation that
I've been wrestling with this all
weekend I think a lot of people been
wrestling with this well it is one thing
to show solidarity online I think that
is important
we're gonna get to some Arian Foster
stuff cuz we had him on part of my tape
my podcast on Monday and he said showing
solidarity online is important and it's
not simply oh you're looking for clout
or oh you're just checking a box it is
important to let people know in your
life where you stand on this shoot in
this issue but what's more important is
the actions afterwards and how you deal
with that afterwards and how you change
as a person how you take what's happened
in the past week 10 days and actually
make changes to try to make the this
country a better country so the NFL
releasing a statement is great but what
what happens afterwards and how do they
how do they talk to their players how do
they let their players you know
peacefully protest before a game do they
try to silence their players like they
did in 2016 that's that is the next big
step I think everyone is in this state
in the last week and a half where
there's a feeling of I want to do more
and I want to be more involved and I
want to help you know in this issue that
is so glaringly obvious and in our face
the the social media is fine you've seen
it time and time again you've seen
brands you've seen you know personal
people I posted a black box on Tuesday
and I talked about all my Instagram
about how I kind of struggled with it
because I usually used to think that
doing something like this on social
media was a little silly but it wasn't
it was a you know it was a moment where
I had to tell people in my life this is
where I stand black lives matter so it's
been very difficult to kind of figure
out that balance of it's okay to post
something it means something to post
something but what comes after that
because that's really the important part
and in a week in two weeks or two months
a year what are you doing to make a
change every single day in your life to
make everything you know work better in
this country to work better and helping
the minority communities you know it's a
great point because how do we
communicate in this day and age how do
we converse we converse through the
social media platforms and the things we
believe need to be put there that's part
of who we are every statement that we
make every message that we post every
image that we find is part of who we are
and if we believe a certain thing
that is the natural place to make sure
the world understands it's the
equivalent of putting a sign in your
front yard in this day and age but
you're right what happens after that and
that's part of what is going to develop
and emerge in the coming weeks and
months and we will be following that
very carefully also the Chiefs and the
Saints did retweet the video the
Patriots the only ones who retweeted
with the message black lives matter but
again that's just part of what the
players want the NFL to say they want
the league to say black lives matter but
they also want the league specifically
the 32 teams to say we support your
right to peacefully protest
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports